(bright electronic music)
- All right, what's up? MKBHD here.
Welcome to the first PC that I have built
in, I had to look this up, nine years.
So I've made a lot of
videos about computers
and we've had prebuilt PCs in here,
but I've never actually built
one from scratch since 2013,
which, if you look back,
was actually a Hackintosh,
but we don't talk about that.
I'm gonna be doing this again
with a bunch of parts here,
and I have decided I'm only gonna be using
YouTuber merch here to build it.
So I've got the desk mat here, mkbhd.com.
I've got a knife, 'cause we've
got someone boxings to do.
This is the JerryRigEverything knife.
You've probably heard of it.
It's pretty sweet. It's actually
the sharpest knife my own.
And then we have this video's sponsor,
yes, actually,
the Linus Tech Tips Screwdriver
both in the Creator Edition
and the regular edition.
But shout-out to Linus and the team
who have been working on this
for apparently three-plus
years to put this together,
which is pretty sweet.
So let's take a look at this one.
Let's unbox the screwdriver.
Oh, they've got the nice
Linus orange colors in here.
So there it is.
Feels very solid.
And you've probably got some bits in here.
So it comes with all 12 of these bits here
and you can store all 12 of
those bits up here in the top.
That's really satisfying. Nice.
Yeah, this is made in
partnership with Megapro Tools,
who has tons of experience
making tools like this.
And there's a magnet in the shaft.
So if you have trouble,
like, grabbing a screw,
that should be no problem.
I'm probably gonna use the Phillips a lot.
I'm just gonna preload that.
Oh, I forgot to mention,
we are gonna be doing a quick giveaway.
Stay tuned to the end for
a little bit of details,
but this is a Creator
Edition of the screwdriver.
And the only thing that means
for me is it's red and black,
which is a special
little bit of a colorway.
So you got the stealth matte black version
and you've got a red and black version.
I'm gonna give these away.
Again, we'll talk about it at the end.
Actually, for this video,
I'm going to build this PC
with the red screwdriver
to be that much more special,
so when I give it away,
you'll have a one of
one that built this PC.
But hey, if you wanna get one of these
in the standard colors yourself, you can.
You can go to lttstore.com
and pre-order yours today.
So I've got all the parts over here.
Let's just go through them one by one.
(upbeat electronic music)
All right, so first
up, we've got the case.
This is CORSAIR's 4000X.
It's a mid-tower PC case
and it's pretty simple.
It's 130 bucks.
It's got some fans in the
front, tempered glass,
rectangle, nothing crazy.
This is just gonna be a
standard high-end PC build.
Then next up, I think it's important
to introduce the motherboard
and the CPU we're using.
This is an ASUS ProArt Z690,
you can see a pretty sweet
black and gold box here,
which is using Intel's 12th
Gen chip here, Intel Core i9.
So we're gonna pop that in there.
And I'll go over all the details
as we start to install them,
but I'm just gonna give
you the quick run through.
The all-in-one liquid cooler for the CPU.
It's CORSAIR's H150i.
It's got a bunch of fans
and it's really solid.
We'll get to that when we install it.
Then I also have here our ram,
64 gigs of ram from G.Skill,
and also a bunch of M.2 SSDs.
They're very fast.
We've got two four terabytes
and two two terabytes.
Yes, the board has enough to support it,
and I'll install them all
in front of your very eyes.
And then last but not least, here is,
we'll get to that,
this is our power supply,
so ASUS 1,200 watt modular power supply
and a bunch of our cables here.
Modular power supply
means, of course, we're
picking our cables.
And our GPU might look
a little bit different.
As you can see, that's an Intel Arc A770.
We've talked about Nvidia
and AMD in the past.
This is a little bit
of a different option.
But I think we'll start
with the motherboard.
(upbeat electronic music)
This is our board.
This is a ASUS's new ProArt motherboard.
This comes with three months
of Adobe's Creative Cloud for free.
So you can kind of get a sense
of who they're aiming at with this board.
All right, wow. It's got some heft to it.
It's a very solid board.
I want to put together as much
of the computer as possible
on the board here in front of me
before I try to put it in the case.
So I'm gonna put the CPU in,
I'm gonna put the ram in,
I'm gonna put the SSDs in,
and then we'll see about the cooler,
how much I can do
before I actually have
to start cable managing
and putting it in the case.
All right, so here is our CPU.
This is Intel's Core i9-12900K
I haven't seen CPU packaging in a while
and this is definitely much
fancier than I remember.
So that's pretty cool.
Twist to open.
This is the fanciest...
Very nice, very nice.
I mean, at the end of the day,
it's a CPU in a plastic case,
but, you know, this is nice presentation.
So I'm gonna not even take it out yet,
but I'm gonna open this latch here
and this will open.
I'm gonna line up that arrow
we see on the bottom corner
with the arrow that I saw here
on the bottom left corner.
I'm just gonna place
that down right there.
So then I'm gonna push this cover down,
push this down,
and our cover pops off
and our CPU is installed.
All right, I'm gonna do ram next.
I think the ram is probably
some of the best-looking stuff
in the inside of a PC,
especially if it has lights
on it, which this one does.
So we've got two sticks of memory here.
These are two 32-gig DDR5 memory sticks.
And you could go double
it up in the future.
I only have four slots on
this board, but that's fine.
And I'm gonna make sure I
install dual channel memory
in the appropriate
slots on the board here.
It's a good crunchy sound
when you do it right.
Beautiful.
We've got our SSDs,
our incredibly fast M.2 SSDs.
And on this board, we have our PCI slots,
but then under these,
we have our M.2 ports.
I'm gonna just use the
screwdriver and pop these open.
What should I use here?
I'm gonna go flathead to unscrew these.
So there's the first M.2 slot.
If you told somebody in
2013 when I last built a PC
that you could get a four terabyte drive
in the palm of your hand,
they would not have believed you.
I would not have believed you.
Trying to tell me that is four terabytes?
Get those pins connected.
They are seated, cool,
and then I'm just gonna push
this down to the screw here
and then use that to lock it in place.
That's actually super easy.
All right, so we've got a bunch more.
I actually don't need all of these drives,
but I'm gonna install some more anyway.
So this is the bottom.
This is the last two
M.2 PCIe 4.0 slots.
I assume they're next to each other.
So actually what's interesting now
is these drives have their own heat sinks
in their little covers, as you can tell.
So my job now is to peel off this cover
and pop the heat sink back on
and that'll be good for the drives.
I'm gonna take this, move it to the side,
and start working on the case.
I'm gonna go power supply
and then we'll go from there.
I'm gonna save this peel
for when it's done.
That'll be my reward.
So, okay, with the door off,
and we can see what's sort of
a canvas we have to work with.
It's got three fans here,
space for the power supply down here.
This is a hard drive bracket,
but we don't have hard
drives in this build.
We have literally terabytes of SSD.
So I think I should just
be able to take that out.
Yeah, matter of fact, let's take that out.
So let's come from the back,
take this other panel off,
and make space for the power supply.
All right, let's take
this bracket out the way.
Oh, thumb screws.
I was about to...
I thought I was gonna have
to use the screwdriver again.
Actually, ooh.
That's pretty tight.
There we go, okay.
(mellow electronic music)
This is the part where gets fun
'cause it's been a long time, like I said,
since I've built a PC.
Power supply.
Yep, solid metal.
All the ROG stuff is so consistently ROG.
Like, the ROG phone looks
like the ROG monitor,
which looks like the ROG power supply,
which looks like the ROG graphics cards.
I mean, these things are consistent.
So as a modular power supply,
it of course comes with a box of cables.
I'm not gonna be using any of these,
but it does have your main power cables
and all that good stuff.
But we're using some CableMod
cables, as you already saw.
I also just noticed this,
just like the ROG phone,
there is a screen on this power supply.
But the thing about this
screen and this case
is it's going to be sitting
in there blocked by the door.
So you're not actually
gonna be able to see it.
But that would just show you, I guess,
the amount of watts of
power you're drawing.
So here, these are the cables
we're going to be using
with this power supply.
CableMod Pro Series Cable Kit.
So the last time I built a PC,
I definitely just used the included cables
with the modular power supply.
Oh, these look way better. Nice.
And these are specifically matching.
These are for this power
supply, which is sweet.
There's a little air intake at the bottom
so we know the orientation
of the power supply in the case,
which will be like that.
And then all the cables
will come into the case
and be routed up the back through here.
So let's start by attaching them.
Okay, so this is actually kind of nice.
It's labeled right here.
So these two are for the motherboard.
This is gonna go here,
which means this is gonna go here.
(mellow electronic music)
Fan down, oriented correctly.
Let's line her up.
All right, so now that
we've got the cables
in the power supply,
the power supply in the case,
I'm just gonna check to make
sure all of our parts fit.
Swivel this around so
you can check with me.
So the board's obviously
got its spot up here.
It's going be oriented that way.
I'm also gonna double-check
this CPU cooler.
It's pretty, I don't
know, it's pretty big.
We'll see if it fits in this case.
And I'm hoping...
Oh.
This is a three fan, three times 120,
it's a 360-mil radiator.
This case is not designed to fit those.
It'll only fit a 240.
We're gonna get a little
bit creative with this one.
Since there are three fans in the front,
that's still big enough for a 360.
So I'm gonna replace the three front fans
with this radiator.
Should still work.
I'm gonna have to take the
fans out, take the front off.
It's a little bit of extra fun.
This is what PC building is all about.
Unfortunately, we'll have
to put the tubes at the top
to get it to actually fit and connect.
You're not supposed to do that,
but, I don't know, LTT spec'd this build
with this exact config.
So I'm gonna make the best of it.
Luckily, I have my handy LTT screwdriver,
which makes this all super easy.
(cash register dings)
So now I'm gonna put these
fans into this radiator.
Typically don't want to
put the cables or the tubes
at the top,
but we're making do
with the parts we have.
So now, next up,
I'm going to put this back
plate behind the motherboard,
which is gonna help us
put the CPU cooler on
and then I'm gonna put the
motherboard in the case.
So I've gotta line up all of these spots.
Okay, so it's actually not too hard.
See, this is nice.
Magnetic screwdriver holds onto the screw.
Pop it in the corner.
I wonder if anyone's ever built a PC
and it just went perfectly.
And our motherboard is now seated.
So then our next step here,
I've got it all ready to put
the CPU cooler on the CPU.
Get it on in one go,
leave it there, screw it in.
Okay, this is the final major piece,
which is the GPU.
This is the different one.
As you guys have probably
seen over the past few years,
AMD versus Nvidia war is raging
on as far as discreet GPUs.
And then when you see an integrated GPU,
it's typically a good Intel one.
They're jumping in the
game of discreet GPUs
and this is the Arc A770.
It's gonna feel somewhere in the range
of an RTX 3060 or 3060 Ti maybe.
You can see the fans on the outside.
It's matte black.
It's kind of a pretty simple
looking card if you ask me.
And I'm gonna be putting it
right in this top PCI slot here.
And this is the RGB controller cable.
So I do have some pins to
get this guy to light up.
Oh, is that the light right there?
Probably. There you go.
Oh, all the way around. Nice.
And it's a dual-slot card.
So I'm gonna need to take the top two out.
(bright music)
That should do it.
So now I gotta line these
up and listen for the click.
(computer parts click)
Yep.
(bright music continues)
I like that.
There's a lot of matte
black going on in this build
and it speaks to me
and I'm very happy with that.
Gotta plug it in.
In fact, we gotta do a whole
bunch of cable management
and cable plugging in.
Nobody really wants to watch me do that.
So with the magic of video editing,
let's fast-forward a couple hours.
All right, here we are.
As you can see, this
is the finished build,
and spoiler, yeah, I did go
a little bit beyond that,
plugged some things in, booted
it up for the first time,
and got everything working.
But I am happy to say the PC works.
It's alive.
I do wanna deliver those last
few peels that I promised.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
I'm pretty proud of the way
the red and black aesthetic turned out.
So here we are now that it's fully booted.
I feel like I learned a lot
both about building a PC today in 2022
with all the new and interesting
parts that we have here,
how clean we are able to make it look.
Obviously having the M.2 SSDs in here
keeps it looking particularly sparse.
There's lots of clean, open spaces,
airflow moving through here.
But also just remembering back
on the other PCs that I built,
which were for very different purposes,
the Hackinstosh was very much a hack.
Like, one of the things
I remember about it
was we literally couldn't turn it off
or it might not turn back on again,
like that type of thing.
This is just an all-round
high-end, fun, great daily driver.
Matter of fact, we got
"Forza" on here already.
All right, in the controls,
I can change video settings to 1440p
and on high at 144 fps.
That should look pretty good.
And now we're way up at 90 to 100 fps.
So you guys might remember
we tried some of this crazy "Forza" demo
on 8K on that machine,
on the super high-end MAINGEAR.
This, even at 1440p on high settings,
which looks incredible,
I'm pretty much locked at
upper 80s, lower 90s fps.
Suffice to say, this Intel
card can definitely handle
some pretty solid gaming.
So this is the screwdriver
I will be giving away.
This exact one.
It's one of one in this
red and black colorway.
I will leave all the bits in it.
This is the exact bit I just
used to finish this build.
And all you have to do
is check the description
and that could be yours.
That's been my first PC
build in a really long time,
and I'm glad I did it.
Thanks, Linus.
Thanks, y'all, for watching.
And I'm gonna get back to gaming.
Catch you guys in the next one. Peace.
(upbeat electronic music)